ancient Sparta had its own way of
speaking Greek they needed it for all
their gruff one-liners but history
pushed them aside as a common dialect
spearheaded by Athens swept the Greek
world yet I'm told there are small
pockets in the south of Greece where
people still cling to the old words the
last remnant of the Spartan tongue a
schoolmaster leads his young students up
the hillsides around leo media cassette
recorders in hand they're on a
self-appointed mission to capture the
words of their elders who speak a Greek
very different from the rest of Greece
these aging villagers are among the few
left who know it for him it used to be a
quirky way of speaking at home around
the table but now he's seasoned it a
lone descendant of Doric crumbling into
yet another Greek artifact Doric yes the
dialect of ancient Sparta
well Athens forged trade routes
generated culture and spoke attic Sparta
was busy speaking Doric and grabbing all
the barracks upgrades they said things
like vomited haha meta
and of course Sparta but in Athens those
odds changed to add a method himera or
get this spot that Sparta's long Alfa's
and military might couldn't stop addicts
from growing into the Greek to replace
all Greeks with one compromise it wasn't
fair to ask everyone to give up all of
their own words why not mix the dialects
a bit so the coin a dialectal common
dialect was born the Hellenic world
expanded and coin a could be heard from
Turkey to Egypt to Italy and Syria if
you head down to Sparta today the Greek
there is the same stuff you hear up in
Athena
huh Spartans even ended up with the
Athenian pronunciation for their own
City nowadays it's well it's spotty
spotty so where did that Doric ah go an
80 kilometer drive down a thin parched
Road morphs into a twisty mountain
passageway that finally leads you to the
schoolmasters quaint town
of little media you'll know you've
arrived when you spot these blue
bilingual signs proudly touting the
local villager Greek on the top and a
translation in hem real Greek one sign
clearly spells out the languages name a
guru sonamoo Amita Sakinaka
ah short and easy like any good Greek
name did you catch it
Saco Nika Barilla if that left you
speaking in tongues call it Ciccone Ian
this might come from the word laconic
not as in wit but as in Laconia the
region around Sparta coincidence or is
there a real ancient connection here
well we already have one way to test
their smartness do they preserve that
Doric alpha where Athenians say eita
listening intently to the children's
cassettes one by one the answer is turn
up they say mati they say a meta but it
gets better
the mother is Amati and the day is our
meta these are as exactly where Athens
gives us e that's enough to raise
eyebrows but there's another rarity
ancient Greek crinkles and suka once had
an ooh that got fronted to e then yo
techies most sounds turning into e left
Greece with pinkish and chica but Sacco
nian still keeps an old ooh Shuko for
knows suka for figs but other words are
unexpected if we're hunting for a
perfectly preserved I like elegant
declensions and conjugations that stood
the test of time in modern Greek get
tossed aside when we listen to psycho
nyan the fancy forms of a verb like
Russell Gaddafi's Gadhafi grapple Megara
photograph oon are reduced to the
poultry participle grass not very
archaic neither is the way they
sometimes say their case sagen figs are
suka and suka but now insert K and fig
and figs cyka cyka this sound change
isn't even unique indeed hellenic
linguists have a term for the extreme
form of it Seeta cosmos pronouncing ten
key as say and see but then
you hear them utter a little V when they
say Avani
the sheep and a vanity a' the U in
Greece those words are supposed to start
with a vowel
everyone does it even before the
Parthenon was built they were doing it
to scholars the reason for this aberrant
beat dies as clear as it is tantalizing
archaic Greek once had a sound whoo
written with a die gamma but it lost it
the root one long ago evolved into um
not here though here these sheep sinews
still start with a very archaic
consonant now pronounced over the pieces
the artifacts the innovation fit this is
a descendant of Doric but it's not
frozen in time it's living its
productive and it's so distinct that
linguists classify it as a separate
language what would it be like if the
dialect of the Spartan survived and
evolved on its own until today
like Sakinaka in a country where coinies
legacy standard greek reaches even the
most nestled towns
Ciccone UNS struggles to keep its
footing I guess tape recorders and
uphill field trips can only do so much
so will you once thought of Spartans as
ancient warriors whose faces and voices
lie buried in the ruins of this town
perhaps with the help of Hellenic
linguistics you can find them in the
faces and voices of another town the
last remnant of the Spartan tongue stick
around and subscribe for language
[Music]
you